i am nick gillespie with my reason
colleague Matt Welch and today is jun 15
2013 we're going to be doing rapid-fire
video responses to your questions from
Twitter Facebook reason.com email you
name it a lot of you asked why are we
doing why a libertarian and why now the
short answer is Matt and I have a book
coming out in just the week or so it's
called the Declaration of Independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America we're going to be
talking about libertarianism and what it
means and how it can help the future of
the country more importantly though
libertarianism is everywhere on the
ascendancy just in the recent New
Hampshire debate of some presidential
candidates for the GOP nod Gary Johnson
should have certainly been in there and
he wasn't but we heard libertarian or
people talking about libertarian ideas
coming up in a five minute stretch which
probably tripled the number of mentions
of the idea of libertarianism for all of
the past US history so libertarianism is
on the rise and that's one of the
reasons why we're talking about it today
and we have intractable problems in this
country that seem to have a movable
politicians behind them and a big theme
of our book is the growth of the block
of independent voters out there why they
have defected from politics and what
solutions they can use to root around
the usual political process to make
things better so that's why we're doing
this today yeah just to get put that
voter question in perspective in 1970
the harris poll said about fifty percent
of american voters identified as
democrats 30-something identified as
republican those numbers from their
latest figures from 2008 it was down in
the low 30s for democrats who was in the
20s for republicans the big growth is in
independent voters and as we'll be
talking about today and we certainly
talked about in the book those
independents are moving towards a
libertarian idea they're interested in
fiscal conservative ism and restraint
and social tolerance and social
liberalism we'll be right back with a
couple more answers